I'm ready to talk about the French revolution and it's hard to do.
And I will leave myself about 45 minutes after I screw around at the beginning.
Um,
and so,
um,
I want to to do two things.
I want to see the revolution through the eyes of maximum,
then Robespierre member of the committee of public safety,
arguably with a sour juice.
I,
it's most important member,
uh,
Jacoba in WWE in a way.
He incarnated a Jacobin Jacabao.
He incarnated the French revolution and I,
and doing so I want to talk about the terror and above all what,
what it was that,
why was that people support it or oppose the revolution.
And that comes down a great deal to religion as we'll see.
But first,
because I promised that we had,
um,
uh,
you know,
the only live bootleg only bootleg guy album of the trial of the king,
I end up his execution.
I thought I'd play those and also the death of citizen Maha in his bathtub.
Uh,
and to do that,
I,
I decided to bring a prop,
uh,
because this is a,
we're going to talk about and I don't mean I'm not making light of a,
of,
of a instant death.
I'm just finished a book about a guy who ends up with,
is him putting his head in the little window.
You knew people were smaller back in those days,
but you really didn't imagine that they were this small.
Do you know what this is what?
This comes from.
This guillotine.
I,
yeah.
Massa.
Do you know what this is for?
Be,
you know,
I mean,
what magic trick.
No,
no.
I mean,
I,
this is a real,
that hurt actually,
when I did that,
I don't write your parents,
especially with freshman to take God,
he was running around.
You're waving a gay teen running,
running around the place.
There he goes again.
No,
it's a first.
The cars.
This is first the gars.
There's your idea.
You did awesome.
Ah,
no,
I don't,
don't smoke.
Don't smoke.
Anyway,
can you put on the,
on the first one,
this is the trial of the King Simon.
Yeah.
Thanks to CD.
This is the,
this is the king.
I'll just translate part and I'm not gonna translate the whole thing.
It doesn't matter if you don't know French.
This is just for Ami off.
This is be off.
Wow.
The,
they're putting them on trial.
He did bad things.
Just I'll try to take part in a minute.
Just takes probably too much time.
But this cool.
Is this from a rock opera
about revolution on phone says Keith Richards live here.
Keith Richards.
Ah,
is this too long to get to it?
Paul dies.
Louie the,
this was his finest
moment.
This is not Louis the 16th
Yup.
They're going to ask him to respond to the charges and the old boy will
answer the act of a,
of accusation,
the indictment,
what you've done against the nation,
but it's nice.
Listen.
Okay.
It's good.
Yeah.
I should have started with the next one actually.
No,
this is it.
Hello.
Among you.
I'm looking for judges and all.
I see his accusers.
I want to do the whole thing.
I never did this horrible thing.
Igneous thing.
Connie.
I never be tried my country,
which is patently false.
Yeah.
Oh,
life has given me some misfortune since death doesn't frighten me at all.
Yeah.
Do France better than me.
Oh,
take care of France.
Better than I could
keep it from its own excesses.
Amen.
Take care of my family.
They didn't come out very well either.
Take care of my children.
It's only favors
that I really,
everyone asks you to carry out.
Yeah.
Jenny Pooley.
Abu Dr. I have nothing more to say to you.
They're going to vote now.
Got Live,
got dead.
Lamar.
Lamar,
Maha.
He'll get his in a few minutes.
Can we get his
two?
Okay,
now the execute the old guy.
Next please.
This is the death of citizen Maha.
He meets Charlotte called day,
who was from Normandy and a royalist.
He's in his bathtub.
I won't translate everything.
Oh,
citizen.
And you're coming in without knocking.
Yeah.
You're seeing citizen my house.
I'll nude in his path.
What's your name?
Charlotte.
Oh,
would you have very nice eyes come here.
Look closer.
What can I do for you?
I won't translate that.
Did you like them citizen?
Why you're looking so mean all of a sudden
to make you afraid.
You bastard you.
What's the knife for?
You heard it alive.
That's it.
Okay.
Yeah.
Cute.
Can we get the lights
please?
Simon,
leave me a little
Maximilian.
Robespierre was born on May six 1758 and a Haas beautiful town,
destroyed more.
We're one in the north of France.
His father was a lawyer who has a son and grandson of lawyers.
His father
married the wealth,
the wife or the daughter of a well do brewer and they were married a few months
before the birth of Maximillian.
Two daughters,
one who died.
This was fairly normal.
Uh,
and Agusta his brother followed is his mother died giving birth to a fifth child
who barely survived her.
The father was unstable,
always leaving home at the time of the birth of all of his children.
He finally died in Germany,
so Robespierre and never had a family cycle.
Historians have done a lot with this,
the family of four with left to care in the care of her maternal grandmother and
by ants.
So essentially he was an orphan at the age of eight.
He felt his father's guilt about causing the death of his wife.
After his sister remembered after his father left,
disappeared,
a total change came about in them forming like all other children of his age.
He was thoughtless and turbulent and flighty.
But since he became the family head,
so to speak,
by virtue of being the eldest,
he's become settled
and responsible.
In laborious,
he spoke to us with the kind of gravity,
um,
which impressed us if it was to take part in our games,
it was in order to direct them.
He loved us tenderly and there were no attentions and caresses that he did not
lavish upon us,
hence forth.
If you buy a psycho historians a interpretation by he could only be a man of
order.
He desperately tried to assimilate himself to the social order he both loved and
hated his father as he adored his,
uh,
dead.
A mother,
his whole life was marked by feeling of his father's guilt,
which also represented the death in a real way of his own childhood.
And then his last hours,
his death wish,
his inability to,
uh,
to act when he might've saved himself a can be seen,
a,
if you will,
in that,
um,
in that context,
he was forced into a seriousness and responsibility.
He always had a passion for,
for solitude,
isolation.
Um,
he knew what it was to be poor.
He was an example,
sort of downward mobility,
if you will.
He went to school and he was really smart,
um,
supported by charitable foundations first in a Haas and then in Paris,
uh,
at age 11 to the collage or middle schools have Louie Louie long where it became
a star classic scholar.
He was selected among all the other pupils to read a poem that he had composed
to,
none less than the king and the Queen as they passed by high ass,
uh,
also in the north of France and champagne country.
But what it,
but as it was raining,
the king and the Queen ordered the driver to go on,
not stopping to listen to Robespierre little speech,
little poem,
and indeed splashing his only good suit of clothes with mud as they draw it up.
And drove off.
He became a lawyer getting this degree in 1780 in Paris,
a lawyer at the Parlor Mall,
uh,
of Paris.
His scholarship pass just things did in the old regime to his younger brother.
He entered prices for literary contest for literary contest that were run by the
academy.
Um,
it once it said,
uh,
that he even caught sight of the great who soul,
but that seems a little unlikely,
but in myths,
uh,
where the academy award him 400 pounds,
which was a lot of,
a lot of money and he was elected to the Academy of a Haas in law cases.
He,
he championed the poor,
the humble.
He took the side of a,
of a man in the Abbey who had been accused by the monks have a theft when in
fact one of the monks had done,
uh,
the ripping off.
Um,
he was,
uh,
he once said,
when somebody was condemned to death,
I know very well that he is guilty,
but I can't imagine just send someone to his own death at the beginning.
But only in the beginning,
he did not believe in capital punishment,
although arguably those who support,
who agree with him would say that he's support.
He saved the revolution by mapping out a capital punishment because of his
reputation.
I mean,
this was a classic case of a,
of a,
of a young lawyer on the make.
He's elected to,
um,
to,
uh,
the,
the jet,
the estates general,
uh,
from Artois.
He's unknown when he goes to Paris,
he's called in the,
in the,
in the minute.
Sometimes we'll call Beth hyphen Pierre.
Sometimes,
well,
best of Pierre,
uh,
sometimes roll Bayer,
I liked the name Roberts ps or sometimes simply you've whole bay,
if that was his first name and Pierre,
uh,
his second name,
but again,
to make a mark speaking always very,
uh,
softly,
um,
68 times he spoke in 1789 and he gradually gets his reputation there.
He opposes all restrictions on the freedom of the press,
and of course that would change later as well.
Uh,
he invokes Russo's concept of the general will,
uh,
to support the view that the king should have no right to oppose or delay
legislative measures proposed by the assembly.
You know,
this,
uh,
from your reading,
he sided on the left of the assembly with those who went to a van to bring back,
uh,
Louis the 16th,
when he and when we have to net try to hire high tail it to the southern
Netherlands or that is to uh,
uh,
to Belgium.
Uh,
that was the king by the way.
He should have been their first,
uh,
tall or am I doing here?
Okay.
That's the king.
Um,
there was an Aha fully clothed
and there are some Maximilian how best Pierre,
although he spoke often,
he lacked presence and in color and this would be the case until the very end.
The English a rider Carlisle saw him as anxious,
slight ineffectual looking man in spectacles.
His eyes troubled,
careful with an upturn face dimly trying to understand the uncertain future
times.
But he spoke with an intense passion and conviction,
a belief in all that.
He said,
immuno bull who died of syphilis,
one of the king's,
uh,
um,
main advisors said of him that man will go far because he believes every single
thing that he says.
He seemed rigid in this principles plane unaffected in this manners.
Nothing set an Englishman of the volatility of a Frenchmen in his character.
Uh,
he supported the idea that all citizens,
all male citizens should have the right to vote.
And thus he opposed the idea of having active citizens who pay taxes and passive
citizens who did not have enough money to pay taxes and thus could not vote.
Um,
he calls for the,
among others with the deposition of the kings being deposed,
um,
both in the legal sense and being deposed from the monarchy.
Um,
he was already known as the incorruptible and he received letters of admiration
once leaving the assembly,
a crowd,
uh,
put,
put oak leaves around him and carried him the city around the city and triumph.
He always wore impeccably white clothes and he wore a powdered wig,
which was very much an old regime thing and not a revolutionary thing.
He was not somebody who's going to go out and to trois,
uh,
easily.
And,
and the revolutionaries to Twan as a form of,
of,
of that is in the familiar form,
like do in,
in,
in German as opposed to z of that familiar form.
All were equal,
therefore you didn't say [inaudible] to people who are above you in the social
ladder.
Uh,
he didn't like people touching them and indeed probably,
uh,
he was chased a,
he had only a few,
a flimsy and only by mail search patients,
uh,
with women.
And when they picked him up,
you have to imagine a sort of crassly American,
uh,
analogy,
but a football coach who sort of swept off his feet after a big upset or
something and,
and he,
he doesn't like people touching him.
He doesn't like being carried away by them.
Uh,
uh,
he,
one of the letters and he was ascetic,
always preferred being alone.
Uh,
eight very modestly,
one letter to him said as current as corrupted,
incorruptible as you are courageous.
And he was that,
uh,
you have always openly displayed your feelings and it's never been self
interested,
has made you act or speak only the general interest he identified with ordinary
people.
Um,
and uh,
he ends up living in western Paris,
a more process part of Paris,
but in the home of a,
of a carpenter,
a on a,
on a street called the full bore Santiano Hay.
And those were really his happiest moments because it,
it,
it provided them with the family.
Uh,
uh,
they had young children in it that he really hadn't had a very normal
circumstance and people who came to see him.
So I'm sort of stretched out on the couch with his family,
trying to guess from the way he looked to what he might want.
Would he want more grapes?
What do you want more milk,
uh,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
he,
he read a lot.
He wrote his speeches,
which were written out by hand.
I'm always welcomed and powdered and the cleanest of dressing gowns.
Uh,
um,
it's a et Cetera,
et cetera.
Now he began to be a frequent user of the Jacoba.
Clo.
Now these clubs like the fool,
y'all and Cordell,
Cordelia and the Jacoba,
we're network called that not because had anything to do with the religious
orders like the Jacabao,
we're religious order because the bill,
the biggest place that you could meet,
we're churches and Abby.
So those are always the biggest buildings.
And so there's Jacoba who are on the left of these clubs,
this begin meeting,
right?
Even before 17,
before the busty falls on the 14th of July,
1789,
uh,
he begins to go to the shackle van club and the Jacoba become the great left
wing centralizers of the revolution.
They trumpet,
uh,
the Authority of the Parisian sans culottes.
And that's a term and other French term.
So important and why it worked its way into English encyclopedia or a dictionary
is a song.
Culottes were those who supported the revolution.
Technically,
if you said a saw culottes with somebody who's not wearing pants,
where that's not what it meant,
what it meant was not wearing fancy kind of aristocratic breaches.
Uh,
and it became a identified with a form of political behavior.
You could be an aristocrat and there were liberal aristocrats,
uh,
in a meeting in a club called the club of the 30,
who helped push the revolution,
uh,
really toward constitutional monarchy,
at least in,
in the beginning.
If you were against the revolution,
you are an I stole your,
an Aristocrat.
If you were for the revolution,
you were part of the book the people.
Um,
and,
and you should,
you chose the color red because red becomes the color,
uh,
of,
of the left wing interpretation of the raffle revolution.
And you gave people kisses on both sides of the cheeks or three times depending
on where you are.
Uh,
uh,
we're in France as a,
as Reckitt recognizing the solidarity you had as being a [inaudible] that as a
male citizen or a [inaudible],
a female citizen as well.
The whole idea of kissing by the way is terribly important,
France,
but that's mostly a late 19th and early 20th century thing.
Uh,
you know,
eat because people really kept their distance.
Whereas now,
you know,
if you live in Paris,
you kiss twice or in the 16th,
around these monad at all.
You really shake hands.
If you live in a Parisian suburbs off and your kiss four times if you live or
we're leaving this live in the south of France,
you kiss three times in the department of the whole,
which is bought along the dock.
If you live in Bez,
Yay,
you kiss three times.
If you live in [inaudible],
which is a more aristocratic city,
traditionally a more formal city,
there was a big university town.
It really rocks,
uh,
you kiss only twice.
But this idea of kissing people on the cheeks was assigned of revolutionary
solidarity and symbols were very,
very important.
If you carried pikes around pikes at the battle of [inaudible],
which you can read about is the pikes of the song culottes that stopped the
highly professional armies of the,
uh,
the enemies of,
of the revolution.
Um,
so,
um,
he,
he believes in the necessity of a single will.
Again,
this comes out of row of,
of,
uh,
esos idea of the general will to save the revolution against its enemies.
And he is one of the people that helps push the French revolution to,
uh,
to the left now.
And his principles were,
were,
were totally unshakeable.
He,
he,
uh,
he doesn't budge on them at all.
Uh,
and of course,
you know,
it's,
it's clean.
It's just insane to look back and see in robes prn or the origins of
totalitarianism despite the committee of public safety.
Uh,
Robespierre,
uh,
also,
you know,
was a man of his times.
He was not against all property.
He was against illegal people having too much unearned property.
Uh,
he thought everybody should have enough,
uh,
to,
to get along,
but that even people who didn't have any property and couldn't invest in panty
taxes,
as I said before,
ought to have the right to vote.
Um,
he also liked the Jocko bath,
believed that the auto have enough,
uh,
to eat.
Uh,
and one of the tensions that one found in the French revolutionary political
clubs and politicals societies and in the sections,
neighborhoods,
sections,
uh,
they began planning how you would defend your neighborhood against foreign
invaders or insurgents from within the price of bread of course,
counted enormously in,
in a couple of weeks.
I'm going to talk about what difference bread made in terms of popular protest
because people who believed in the kind of free trade,
that two,
we'll go ahead in the,
in the,
you know,
the,
in the,
uh,
18,
seventies believe that the market audit determine the price of bread.
Uh,
but there was always a tradition that,
that,
that the price of bread ought to be kept at a reasonable amount so that
everybody ought to have,
uh,
have,
um,
enough to eat.
And so the [inaudible],
most of them believed in sight in,
in,
in the maximum,
the maximum,
which was a maximum on the price of bread.
Now they're,
uh,
their enemies,
on the,
the level revolutionary left or serve left central,
we're called as you hone down,
which I room,
I wrote on the board.
And a name I sent around on the class server,
the your home down a Gir,
O,
n,
d,
I,N ,
s,
which is also the name of the Boldo soccer team.
I were from a Boldo and,
and the department of this Yo honed many of them were,
they are merchants.
They are free trade people.
And they also were extremely interested in launching foreign wars,
uh,
to,
um,
carry liberty fraternity and,
uh,
quality,
abroad.
Now I'm scrambling for this great quote.
Uh,
the gentleman down,
we're in love with,
with war.
And there was this great kind of rhetoric about conquest and,
um,
and caring freedom,
uh,
in quotes,
to,
uh,
to other countries though one,
one had to be,
and many people were cynical about this when the,
when the French troops poured into the rent into the Rhineland,
uh,
the prostitutes of,
of,
of the Rhineland cities,
uh,
dressed up in red,
white and blue flags,
uh,
to welcome,
their new,
uh,
a new clients.
Um,
Robespierre I made a series of speeches against this,
this brie soul who was the former,
uh,
a grub street writer that I mentioned before argument that France should not go
to war.
He said that,
and more about this in a minute,
that the danger to the revolution did not come from a hand full of emigres,
uh,
in Germany,
but from one in France,
from the counterrevolution.
And that's important and that's worth underlining.
And secondly,
he argued that launching wars all over the place when merely play into the hands
of the king,
who at this point was still the king and the counter revolutionaries,
perhaps paving the way for some sort of military dictatorship.
How a forward looking was that because that's exactly what they ended up with,
of course,
with Napoleon.
Moreover,
you argue that war would separate soldiers from the rest of the people.
And,
and indeed,
although the Levee en masse,
my guillotine almost fell down.
Uh,
um,
uh,
w w w w would,
would sort of compromise that because all citizens become soldiers,
uh,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
But he said something.
This,
uh,
this is an amazing little speech that he gave and I'm going to read just a few
lines of it because if you think about a current politics in this country in the
last,
say five years,
uh,
it may also a ring true.
He said the most,
this is Robespierre the most extravagant idea that can arise in a politician's
head is to believe that it's enough for a people to invade a foreign country to
make it adopt their laws and their constitution.
No one loves armed missionaries.
The declaration of the rights of man is not a beam of sunlight that shines and
all men,
and it is not a lightning bolt,
which strikes every thrown at the same time.
I am far from claiming that our revolution will not eventually influenced the
fate of the world,
but I say that it will not be today.
Amazing.
He lost this debate,
uh,
in 1792.
Um,
and in fact,
his denunciation of plots against the revolution may have contributed,
contributed to revolutionary paranoia.
Uh,
which would it be acting out,
uh,
in the tear.
But on the 20th of April,
1792,
they should own de and the king got their wish,
a war and war was declared on Austria and French troops crossed into Belgium.
That is the Austria and Netherlands and the wars,
uh,
went,
went on and on.
Now,
um,
I want to make a couple of points that are,
that are pretty important.
I'm not going to use these,
these papers to do this.
Um,
that the threat to the revolution did not come just from Austria,
from Great Britain,
from Prussia,
from Russia,
from uh,
the big allies and Robespierre got this right.
There are two in the timing of that.
You can read about it in the,
in the,
in the chapter and please do.
Um,
uh,
there were two main counterrevolutionary um,
threats to,
uh,
to the revolution.
The first,
which was,
was not the most important,
but still it's worth mentioning was what has been called the federalist revolt,
the federalist revolt.
And this was based in cities in which merchants free traders played a big role
in that.
Here is a map of lob,
better Fossa.
Um,
now Boldo we've already talked about you've got all these wine merchants at all,
all this family fancy land and who merchant other things as well.
Uh,
you've got Maasais big Trudeau is not yet the huge port.
It become in the 19th century.
We've gotten Maasais you've got the all then Francis a second city first and
astronomy one could still argue,
uh,
today.
Uh,
the hen was merely where the king is,
is,
is caught.
That's up there.
Uh,
by the way,
in 1790,
they,
in order to undercut local elites,
that is clergy and nobles and also to impart a more rational organization of the
country comes right out of the enlightenment or the philosophic.
They create deep,
hot tamale departments and they named most of them after rivers.
So some are named after mountains and they create a capital in each of them.
For example,
this,
it doesn't mean none of this matters,
but it's just to tell you what's going on.
That's,
it would VN the capital the most.
the co has capitalism tune up there as to cause a capitalist go,
Hey,
uh,
this is the long Moana my song.
Uh,
this is the,
the,
the Pyrenees,
the Atlantic pier,
and he is the capitalist pull,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
so these,
the federalists revolt also in comp,
that's where we're,
the aforementioned Charlotte called.
They came from,
uh,
from that part of it.
That's the department of the kind of a dose,
which is also the name of a wonderful apple brandy.
Uh,
so,
so the,
the federalists or volt comes instead,
he's light.
Like it comes in above all in [inaudible] a call Mousey,
uh,
too long.
And Leon and of course,
uh,
the revolutionary armies,
the armies of ordinary citizens in the republic,
uh,
what has becoming,
becoming a republic,
a crush,
crush them,
they crush them like grapes.
Uh,
in Leon,
uh,
one of the members of the committee of Public Safety,
who I was confined to a wheelchair,
a man named [inaudible] that you can read about.
N a.
It says he's going to plow a Leo under,
uh,
like Carthage,
and they do execute people on the plus a better core.
Um,
and so this federalist revolt is against the bow.
It's against the suppression centered,
uh,
far left interpretation of,
of the French revolution.
By the way,
their groups on even further to left on the Jacobean really weren't that far to
the left,
but,
but are groups like the enraged Lee's own.
Hi,
Jay.
Uh,
there's even a guy called [inaudible] [inaudible],
uh,
who believed that,
you know,
that pop for the,
that,
uh,
property should be abolished,
but these are,
these are just a very small groups of a is a guillotine and Vom Dome,
uh,
which is south of Paris,
near the Luau.
And his trial is a wonderful source,
actually the trial of [inaudible] Bofa and original source.
So anyway,
so that's the federalist of all.
But the most important threat to the revolution comes from peasants.
It comes from,
uh,
peasants in the west of France,
also down where we live in this part of France to a,
that comes later.
But basically what I'm going to talk about for a few minutes is the revolt,
uh,
in the west.
Um,
now it was often said that peasants would never march more than a day away
further from their fields,
but certainly,
you know,
as mile and lots of other people have shown,
uh,
or Hokey men,
that's not the case at all.
Um,
uh,
and,
um,
the,
the war was fought with a savagery with a brutality to was simply,
you know,
a staggering,
uh,
I,
there were massacres on both sides,
uh,
that,
the,
the Von Day,
which is in dark,
there is an,
it became a department,
a number 80 goodwill number 85.
Um,
uh,
and,
but it became such a,
a major blood bath that,
uh,
that they'll entire,
counter revolution in the West is often simply called the von day.
I am in the history,
literally because I read a long time ago,
uh,
a book written by my late and must much missed friend,
Charles Tilly,
uh,
called the Von Day,
which sought to explain and did explain,
uh,
and really hasn't been nuanced very much over the decades.
Why some people opposed to revolution,
uh,
taking big time chances,
and other people and who didn't live that far away,
uh,
supported the revolution.
Um,
and so when he found he studied in an area that it doesn't matter where,
but what sort of the north of that,
of that dark area,
uh,
actually in the many Lularoe a different department,
but um,
in,
here's another French word that's also English.
In the bulk cottage country,
BOC age,
it's the hedge row country.
And he found that the,
the people who rose up against the revolution and took mid big time chances.
I mean,
the Republicans didn't screw around and there was a lot of just horrible
brutality.
They drown thousands of clergy in the swirling waters of the,
of the,
of the lower river,
which is a very dangerous river by putting them out into the river with holes
drilled in the bottom of the boat,
which didn't give him a big hope.
They killed lots of people on the East Bay,
which is up here off la,
La Rochelle.
Uh,
and of course,
uh,
the,
the force is representing the monarchy representing the nobles were if anything
even more brutal.
They crucified people.
Literally they,
they,
you know,
they made them,
uh,
you know,
kiss the cross before they beat them to death.
Uh,
I mean,
it was really,
uh,
it was really a nasty time.
Um,
and so,
but,
but looking at it,
people who,
who rebelled and,
and ones who didn't,
that the areas,
one of the things we can say at least by that particular area,
but it really rings true is it areas in which that traditional elite,
noble and priest had not been broken down by the economic and social changes of
the 18th century.
They were physically isolated.
These hedges,
you see them up in the upper part of Norman d to uh,
uh,
I mean lower normally,
but,
but high up there on the nearest,
uh,
share,
um,
in the mosh,
you,
these are huge hedge rows that you literally,
I mean,
we can't fight your way through and you can't really climb over and people
tended to marry within their village or within a nearby village.
They still,
uh,
the priests will walk tall.
Uh,
the noble was somebody who,
uh,
who they still respected,
even though the noble nobles had left.
Many of them are left and even though many of they still had to pay pay dues to
the nobles and their only contact with this kind of bourgeois world of economic
change was with people were farming taxes,
for example,
who may hated people that were putting out work into the countryside,
who cheated them and said,
well,
I told you I'd give you five sue last time.
But there are a lot of women doing that same work.
I'm going to give you three.
And if you don't like that too bad,
I'll walk away and I won't take the cloth work that you've done for me,
too bad for you.
Uh,
or people that collected the taxes for the nobles.
And so if you look up further along the La River where you had this sort of
economic change in the 18th century,
people accepted this new lead and they were easy.
They were willing to ditch the idea of the monarch.
It wasn't say that they all went red or blue soul instead of the Bible before
they went to bed.
Uh,
but these,
these are big time changes that reflected,
uh,
they're reflected the way things had evolved.
Now let me give you some more,
uh,
some more examples.
Um,
now one of the most important moments of the French revolution,
and this is also worth remembering and that you can read about it,
uh,
the civil constitution of the French clergy because the revolutionaries get the
very good idea that you're broke.
You already know that the monarchy just flat broke.
So where are you going to get the money?
Who has,
who has money?
Well,
nobles who leave France have money because they have a lot of property,
particularly in areas like Brittany and then in Burgundy,
uh,
Eh,
you know,
and then the end of the false that is the,
the island of France around Paris.
Um,
but the church has enormous amounts of money,
enormous amounts of land.
So what they do is they essentially nationalize the church,
the details you can get and they forced people to take an oath to the French
revolution,
to the nation,
to the nation.
Now in certain parts of France,
particularly those that rose up against the revolution,
the priests don't take the oath,
they refused to and they are called non during.
That is non swearing priests,
G in other parts of France,
uh,
the priests were more willing to take the oath and they're called Jurin clergy.
So this is important.
If you just look at this map,
you see,
uh,
this is by co,
this is by a calm,
tall captains,
uh,
within departments.
But did you see all that white up in Brittany and those revolutionary areas that
corresponds exactly to the area of people who fought against the French
revolution?
Because the clergy still has enormous influence and sort of the nobles,
even if they're,
you know,
living in England at the moment are living in Britain,
are living living in Austria and Netherlands or in a,
in a the Rheinland or somewhere else in Germany.
Um,
so,
but,
uh,
this isn't enough.
I mean that,
that's not enough because we have to see really what,
uh,
here we go.
This is by district.
This is even better map of it.
Uh,
and you see that in the central part of France here,
uh,
that people,
priests refuse to swear allegiance as in our village to the French revolution.
But in Brittany and enormity,
they did massively.
And in Alsace and Lorraine,
they didn't massively.
And in the north of France,
they did massively.
So,
okay,
but that's fine.
That's interesting.
But so what's going on here?
What's going on?
Why did it,
does a goal like that?
It's not just that people also get together and say,
you know,
let's,
let's not swear to the revolution.
Let's,
you know,
go have a drink with Calvin dose instead.
Uh,
uh,
more important changes are going on.
Now,
the word de Christianization,
which I also sent around,
has two meanings.
One is the campaign against the church by the revolution,
revolutionaries to melt down church bells,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Uh,
um,
de Christianization to change the calendar so that it's no longer January,
February,
March,
but it's a germy now Thermador von toes names they have to do with winds and
plants and the agricultural calendar.
That's part of decriminalization,
but that's not the big issue.
The issue is that in these areas that old,
that in which the revolution was accepted,
that old time religion was on the rope.
A friend of mine was a greatest story and called Michel Valle longtime ago.
I did a book on decriminalization.
He looked at part of provosts and he looked at how people,
what they did with their money in,
in wills,
they looked at the number of people who became priests or nuns.
Uh,
he looked at,
you know,
at,
all sorts of things.
Well,
how many people baptized their children within the three days you were supposed
to in the Catholic church.
And what he found is that the church,
it wasn't the revolution that destroyed,
uh,
the role of the church or the reduced the role in ordinary people's lives that
that had already happened.
And it began after the counter ref ref reformation.
That is the Catholic reformation.
I was already well underway by the 17 thirty's and the 1740s.
So you can see political behavior here reflecting these big time,
important trends.
You know,
it's in another way you can look at bishop sermons.
You look at how people name their children,
uh,
you know,
in the 19th century when they start ne stop naming their children after,
after a saints,
local saints,
for example.
That's another good indication.
Or you know,
you don't have many people named Mary Magdalen anymore in France or that kind of
thing.
Or in the was Zahn named [inaudible] or they now,
and these names of local,
local saints.
So these,
and,
and here again,
the areas that were counterrevolutionary,
uh,
you know,
Eh,
particularly up in Brittany and,
and,
and you know,
what to,
and those regions there,
uh,
there's some,
the big story was these major kinds of of change.
Ultimately what I'm saying then his religion was very likely to be,
uh,
arguably the most important cause for,
um,
for,
uh,
people,
supporting or opposing,
uh,
other revolution.
Uh,
particularly the radical revolution is the committee of public safety sat around
this Big Table,
uh,
and made a big decisions.
Now what about the terror itself?
That they're,
the interpretations of the tear basically have gone like this one.
It was sort of a bloodletting by the very poor of their social betters.
Well,
that's pretty much nonsense.
Uh,
secondly that it's a reflex action to save the republic.
Will that makes more sense.
Uh,
basically in somebody in the 1930s,
you know,
before there was really quantitative history,
went to look,
a guy called Donald Greer said,
let's look at the victims of the tear.
And when he,
he finds fits into where we started,
which is Maximilian Robespierre.
And his attempt to save the revolution,
um,
that the most people in the tear,
uh,
there was a higher percentage of clergy and nobles executed because they're
small percentages of clergy,
uh,
and particularly nobles in the French population.
But the vast majority of people that either were given a prison sentences or it
put their heads to the little window,
uh,
or were shot down,
executed like as,
as in a executed as in Leone,
uh,
were,
were and we're artisans.
Why?
I mean,
cause there was more peasants and artisans and above all peasants in France and
the other social group.
Now that's,
that's good.
I mean,
that's good to know that,
but even more important that the incidence of the tear in the French revolution,
common areas that are battle zones,
that they reflect,
you know,
the war,
the professional soldiers of other,
of monarchies fighting in the north of France are fighting the east of France.
And they reflect,
uh,
the reflect the civil war is that people get,
a lot of people were,
were put to death or executed,
uh,
cause they were fighting or participating in,
in,
in supplying troops in battle zones.
It's possible as my friend David Velez argued to say that parts of this
represent the first total war.
I'll talk more about that when we get to Napoleon cause it's,
it's,
um,
it's an interesting subject.
But anyway,
uh,
the,
the terror was no,
was no sort of bloodletting,
organized,
bloodletting,
uh,
or spontaneous.
It was that too,
despite the horrible incidents,
despite not,
and despite the massacres in the prisons in,
in,
uh,
I September massacres and,
in,
in Paris,
uh,
you know,
there was a logic to this and it had to do with,
uh,
trying to,
save,
uh,
the revolution.
Now I'm back to
back to Maximilian Kolbe is a PA,
I'm fumbling through his papers here to get to the appropriate point.
Um,
they tried to kill Robespierre of course,
that's the,
as the terror gets,
uh,
gets more organized and,
and he had a tendency as his sounds used and the other ones that say,
if we just have one more tear,
one more round of tear will finally save the revolution and all will be well.
But lots of people,
uh,
in,
you know,
in the assembly,
uh,
looked around reasonably enough,
and said we might be,
uh,
the next,
the next victims.
Uh,
he became increasingly tired,
fatigued.
He was never a,
you know,
a,
a dramatic speaker.
But he was,
if he no longer wanted to be heard,
um,
two attempts on his life,
it finally got him to come to the Jacobin club and to go the convention.
It's possible to argue that death and revolutionary in mortality was,
um,
was something that he chose because of his own childhood guilt,
uh,
a primal guilt,
about,
uh,
his own father and,
the death of his,
uh,
a mother,
for somebody who is aesthetic and,
and withdrawn and preferred to be alone.
Uh,
he became increasingly of that way unable to,
uh,
to act in a 17,
in 1794.
And Thermador the month of Thermador.
Um,
he became increasingly obsessed with his own and his own demise,
he says,
of providence has seen fit to snatch me from the hands of the assassins.
It was to ensure that I would profitably employ the moments that still remained
to me,
yet he could only,
uh,
you know,
as people how let them from every conceivable angle,
uh,
in the convention,
a murmur,
uh,
um,
almost inarticulately.
Uh,
when he,
he mounts the rostrum on the eighth of Thermador,
he gives an incredibly clumsy speech for Robespierre.
I need to unburden my heart.
Everyone is in a league against me and against those who hold the same
principles that I hold.
What friend of the nation would wish to serve the moment the,
the,
the nation when he no longer is allowed to serve it.
Why remain in an order of things in which intrigue eternally triumphs over
truth?
How may one bear the torture of seeing this horrible succession of,
uh,
of traders?
Perhaps he thought that his own death with rouse,
the Patriots,
that is the Sans Culottes,
uh,
in,
in the sessions in the neighborhoods,
uh,
of,
of particularly central,
uh,
in,
um,
and eastern Paris.
Um,
11 times,
uh,
he is shouted down and people shouting down with the tyrant and he says,
only I ask for death.
He leaves with his brother and with tall,
and they go to the town hall.
The same building is not there,
but it's in the same plot,
the same spot.
And they weighed upstairs.
And occasionally somebody would say to them,
well,
why don't we go out and rouse up the sections?
Why don't we,
you know,
we are at great risk here.
And they just sit there.
They sit in this,
in this room.
They sit there all night.
And finally,
inevitably,
uh,
the troops of the conspiracy run up the stairs,
cutone tries to escape in his wheelchair and the wheelchair bounces along with
him down the stairs.
Robespierre either takes a pistol and shoots himself in the jaw or is shot and
the,
and the jaw.
And he spends time trying to rub the blood because of the,
he had this thing about clean,
clean white clothes and Andy for,
until they know what to do with him,
he at one point he's lying on a table and he points with sounds juice.
They point to the declaration of the man of the rights of man and of citizen.
And they said,
we did that.
Uh,
and indeed they did.
And they find themselves taken to the concierge.
Sorry,
that is the prison of the conversation of hey,
which is still there.
It's no longer a prison is one of the great gothic halls,
one of the three great gothic halls and France along with,
and y'all and,
and most of them,
Michelle.
Uh,
and of course the trial is,
is as he would have had it and had it for the enemies of the revolution is quick
with no defense,
really permitted.
Uh,
uh,
the next morning they clip his hair back,
as one did a so that the long hair,
uh,
would not in any way slow the blade of the guillotine.
And they take him,
put him in a wagon and it takes,
because there wasn't very good way.
They're not major thoroughfares through Paris.
They take him to the Plus Dilla Revenue Shawl,
which is now called the Plus luck Hong Kong.
And they pass him by his house.
Uh,
the host of the carpenters with he,
which he stayed where he had had his happiest moments.
And as he gets closer to the plus,
uh,
deliver revenues,
show where he's going to meet Sasol the executioners or are all,
it's a blood trade after all.
And rather like butchers,
they all intermarrying and they lived outside the walls of cities.
He's going to meet SAS song as he gets there.
He surely noticed that the women were more and more well dressed and so are the
men.
And as he gets there,
they're,
they're shrieking at him,
uh,
of obscene term to go with down with the maximum,
the maximum on the price of bread.
It's a different crowd.
It's a very different crowd.
Thousands of people came to hear the lean forward to catch the last words,
to see the head held above as they did with Louie the 16th,
and with Marie Antoinette's.
Uh,
uh,
hold my head up.
It's a good one.
Said Down Tall,
uh,
or something like that.
When they executed him on San Juice and roves peers orders before and he meets
Sasol with his,
with blood pouring out of his,
the bandage holding his jaw on having come loose.
And even at the end,
even if they shove his head into the little window,
uh,
blood is pouring from him and wonder when does it,
no,
we can't imagine.
As he looked up,
as his head is down and he looks up,
he sees the throngs of paid a fine price to sit on the roofs,
like living in being across from Wrigley field or something like that,
to see the death of the tyrant tyrant or the person who saved the revolution,
or one of them.
It's very hard to say,
uh,
it,
it depends on your view,
but certainly one can imagine that Robespierre a brief,
uh,
a breathe,
a breath of,
of,
of a relaxation of,
of leaving a in existence that had tortured him.
Uh,
and if gaining for the revolution,
he hoped Revolution Neri revolutionary immortality,
but also perhaps when can argue paying a debt,
a debt to his family that,
uh,
stemmed from the death of his own mother long before in a Haas.
See,
on Wednesday.